Oh y'all ready yeah she ready okay
so Tiffany Haddish kids say the darndest
things you say the darndest things do I
cited honestly funny as hell I'm just
honest I'm just honest and that's what I
love about these kids they're just
honest and they're saying what they
think and I think that's the best thing
kids need to be heard I know the old
saying Oh kids should be seen and I
heard and I remember being that kid and
hating that saying and wish wishing
people would listen to me just a little
bit because I might be a kid but I'm not
all the way crazy yep
I'm not a kid anymore no and I hope
people listen from time to time yeah and
I might be all the way crazy now but
that's because nobody was listening this
series you're hosting it we are also the
executive producer so why did you feel
so strong about recreating the series
well because it gives children a voice
right and I and I think that's really
important especially for self-esteem
wise growing up being able to
communicate with others and and having
that voice and letting other kids see
like hey somebody cares and and we can
be heard and we can say what we believe
as long as you do it in a classy way
mm-hmm so there's a lot of new fun
segments this time around
what can the audience expect what you
guys can expect some really funny
commercials that I'm doing with the kids
some little pranks here in there and
scenarios where you know we try to sell
movies and things of this nature
with me and the kids you know yeah
what's it like getting romance and
dating advice from the children well you
know what sometimes the kids have the
best advice yeah now I took some advice
from John Mayer not too long ago didn't
really work out there but I appreciate
him trying but these kids they usually
give the best advice the best tips um
you know one young lady told me just
stay single like a Pringle tip just a
single like a Pringle and I said well
you know what yes she has no idea what
it's like to be grown kids have no
filter so what was one thing
shooting this series that some kid said
to you that was the most shocking what I
have said some things to me I can't
think of one particular moment that
really shocked would you know well I
mean they've running those commercials
now to young me and I was talking about
his job working at the bowling alley hmm
that was like it was hilarious and
shocking but not that shocking but it
was hilarious but some young ladies tell
me that they're married already and
they're like four no I'm on my third
marriage in I'm five
you know like wait what are you talking
about her marriage yeah yeah you've
accomplished so much in the last few
years and I know you're coming on your
40th one for the 18th year it's online
Thanks what if they all say I wear a
size 8 mavs shoe that's a lot what size
do you wear
I wear a mine and I'm tired of these
lies they also say you know I wear a
size 8 in jeans that's a lot what what
size I'm a 1000 perfect here you better
tell everybody yeah given that you were
coming up on this birthday it's gonna be
a conic because it is the 40th we I know
we'd established that that's what I got
for the 19th year yep yeah in front of
19th birthday are you approaching any
new goals is there anything you really
want to accomplish that you haven't done
yet I want to have a bat mitzvah I'm
getting Mitzvahed hmm
on December 3rd mmm yep and on that same
day my black mitzvahs coming out on that
flat mmm girl oh but I want I want to be
us against a woman who I feel like at
that point you know now I'm 21 for the
19th year come December the 3rd that I
will officially be a woman yeah so I'm
gonna have a mitzvah I'm having a bat
mitzvah you can come if you want to it's
gonna be poppin I would love to I got a
rabbi and everything
I left my bar just a female robot a
robot
okay and if you think I'm playing this
I'm dancing ruling everything girl don't
get me started
oh not a Hebrew is here because we're
not you know would have really the real
try hmm Oh had me start it yeah is there
anything get me the kicking you
knowledge girl you're not ready I don't
know if you're ready I'm ready
did you have your Mitzvah yet no no cut
me know is there any kind of group huh
you can get for this birthday cuz you PU
put me on you put the invitation only
oh okay invitation only okay you could
come through I'm inviting you to I'm
there it's summertime we're gonna have
fried locks and everything all right
it's a black mitzvah okay well I mean a
bat mitzvah
it's a bot black Mitzvah payoff you
there cuz I'm a girl
you know black no it's Mitzvah okay I'm
with it I'm there I'm so happy
um Tiffany you are a pleasure thank you
and I'm gonna watch the show and Joe you
already know thank you